my god today we're going vertical with
pole dancing I have never done pole
dancing before neither have I I've been
on a little bus I had a pole before but
this is my first pole dancing class they
put us in these little booty shorts and
I'm kind of feeling myself right now
learning pole dancing as a couple it's
empowering it builds confidence and you
also you know lose weight you tone up
you build muscle I feel like if there's
no major injuries today that it will be
a success so we're gonna start chest out
booty I'll step dry I want to see you
looking at yourself in the mirror like
yeah you sexy [ __ ] in the mirror there
you go
so the first move that we are going to
learn today is the fireman spin you're
going to take it down to the balls of
your feet
that's mine yeah yeah the next move that
we are going to learn is the cradle spin
swing that left like in these two chests
here we take it all there you go better
we're like the best dance crew ever our
last move is going to be the cross knee
release oh every man in the room is 102
advanced look at that this is look I got
some of us don't have the thigh meat
require there's such a separation ever
done now imagine this your testicles in
it yeah teamwork makes the dream work
writing up fights for me
oddly Asian life that's holy hmm you did
it to win it
okay okay
Oh
okay
Oh
yes
yes yes look at that where's my ones I
need my one
today I soared through the air like a
graceful canary my crotch burns I like
putting my legs out like this it's a
full workout like I got an upper body a
lot of course change I stress tested
both of my testicles today doing it as a
couple is a lot of fun getting to
perform for each other as well I'm sorry
mom when will we ever be in a video that
we can show our parents is my question